okay so I want to give you a little
heads-up on this one if you saw the
first viewing before this you know we
watch Green Lantern and we were drinking
a little bit it was a really bad movie
so by the beginning of this were a
little toasted little tipsy
we are smashed by the end of this Rob is
on the floor I'm slurring my words like
crazy repeating myself over and over and
yeah if you're just wondering like what
is wrong with them it's because we had
to watch these back to back we're really
drunk this is how much of the Bourbon we
start out with and this is what we ended
with if we're acting drunk we are we're
sorry we don't usually do that but we
need booze to get through this one so
apologies or maybe none eated because
you know you're getting a laugh out of
it but that's what's going on so here it
is
oh okay so this is our first viewing of
kangaroo jack if you've watched our
Green Lantern you know we are filming
this immediately after we have the same
clothes we're still a little toast we're
a little tipsy cuz Green Lantern was bad
place your bets
wave a you think Green Lantern's gonna
be worse a kegger Jack's gonna be worse
it's quite sure it's like choosing
between your own children I'm gonna say
Green Lantern I think our Jack's gonna
be you run the mill dumb kids playing oh
man I'm gonna bail this couch let's just
do it this is kangaroo jack rip the
band-aid off what Bruckheimer I just
love that they inserted kangaroos into
that as if they're just like no this
films important enough already this is
better than Green Lantern cuz walking is
it critic they promised me cake who we
do I want to be a kangaroo dude why an
hour in Captain Underpants really just a
football falling in the water you had to
slow-mo that what the fuck what the
flying fuck what the flying fuck I just
gonna say alrighty this is already a
better superhero film the Green Lantern
can actually save somebody
anybody got yeah Green Lantern movie is
front-loaded as fuck a lot of exposition
for kangaroo jack Michael Shannon yes
Christopher Walken and Michael Shannon
in a kangaroo movie produced by Jerry
Bruckheimer I'm and that seems good be
coop but like I'm interested
hop over her that'll be amazing if the
black kid in the Superman cape snaps
Michael Shannon's dead have you ever
seen a good movie the hair like an ice
cream truck man and it ever
I think don't just beat on my leg you
know I get it
Hollywood actors you'll take whatever
kind of job you can get but we have to
read the line I think the dog just peed
on my leg do you say shit paycheck just
think of a paycheck Brent you know it's
between prison and carrying my fucking
dog I dropped the dog this is a common
thing do criminals just hang out in this
guy the cops just point up like a
ceiling okay to me
anatomy don't make me keep doing this
I'm doing it
shit my hands oh it slipped out here
help me scoop it up American Pie has
nothing a kangaroo jack I just love
insane stock footage
yeah but painfully obvious seemed to go
super grainy there for a second I'm so
really there wow that's bad this isn't
even enough for a short film just call
the movie flimsy pretext born out of one
of Bruckheimer's drunken kickers those
two kangaroos before it's like he's one
of them it's just so weird I feel like
I'm watching a puppy die in slow motion
it's both of that slow enough and not
fast enough
yeah you can make a fine chair out of
that shirt you know we're still paying
reparations to Australia for this movie
epileptic dude
no wasn't shut the fuck up it's kind of
like the drunks Santa Claus or her
deceased Christmas there in one image
that was a metaphor this movie
kangaroo just watchin a fiery crash
could even do that right he just saw it
go down with a pop of smoke that would
have been funny but no they have to cut
back again I'm sure Bert Kammerer is
like no no more boom-boom
that's all of brookheimer x' notes he's
like just I think something bad is about
to happen here Louis I think that's what
the actors said to each other after
reading the script I think something bad
is about to happen just trying to say
get out of the movie
it's kangaroo jack I think it's terms of
endearment free but it's not my god yeah
no shit it's a mirage oh I feel like a
dog you just gotta be used just accept
it as like master like you my dog we
shows that dog right now garbage yeah
I'm sure she will look that good in the
desert kids film
Wow love the jacket Charlie nope no we
should rip this other enemies come piece
of cake or Jack what what's this Bigfoot
do you think the animators were proud to
animate this scene do you think they put
this on their resumes obviously I think
they put this on their signed confession
good night Ned when you get back up here
by the way maybe kind of an obvious
question but why the fuck is she
American you know just a nice Chilean
there'd be fine that was know maybe
they'll make it unrealistic unlike
anybody falling in love with this guy
you can't be down there the whole time
oh you have burning camels I'm really
shocked I didn't predict that at the
beginning of the film oh you really
think that's funny movie don't you
you're like really working that like
guys we got it farting camels I mean
this is it
it doesn't get bad this is it retracted
we cracked humor farted camels fuck yes
just farted to do like we got this we
got the comedy thing
Jaclyn Robin blames those idiots we got
the wheel kangaroo god damn fucking jack
shit
Barney Gamble's it just let my goddamn
mind they're actually that was
Christopher Walken's contribution god I
think this meets with more bobbing
camels can you Jack they cracked the
code the goddess party camels that was
it we're drawing for your long Jerry
Bruckheimer's you two more companies
goddamn it shit fuck ass fuck
farting Tibbles yes oh who are the few
assholes who gave this thing in 8% of
Rotten Tomatoes how is this not zero I
use my lip gloss to distract the
Kangaroos in the wildlife bingo Dingle
where no no no no no bingo he was heard
that the be for a D that's bingo bingo I
am so glad people get paid for this
I don't care what you do take a second
swig finish what you started I'm looking
for a missing kangaroo Michael Shannon
just said that line what do you say to
that oh wow like a wet TNA shot in a
Bruckheimer film I'm shocked okay I'm
fucking Punk
I'm gonna no threats just kill him
two Yanks tragically cocking an apology
yeah boots were all made up words 16
Taiwanese all-stars to this day this
movie really likes to steal soundtracks
from other movies which I'm okay with
because the actual soundtrack is awful
did this movie have a soundtrack yeah
that's every Bruckheimer movie just very
expensive it's amazing thank you fuckin
Christ
I would we repay a thousand dollars
right now if this ended with a giant
killing spree ending all of them just
like shoot each other and then the
camels and the kangaroos eat the corpses
well yeah but it's like nasty ass like
blood farts to pay the court I feel like
everyone in this movie wasn't told the
title everyone thought they were making
like a cinematic version of Breaking Bad
they were told they were acting opposite
Robert De Niro but they were gonna
insert him in later be a CGI how the
movie did they realize it was a fucking
kangaroo always very method that way
Yeah right this is what it's all about
that's all Howard it's about the
connection between these two you think
we're friends cuz you saved my life once
you saved my life every day Lewis shut
up important lessons about not dressing
the corpses of Ken
and kids remember that hit a kangaroo
don't put your jacket on him that's the
goddamn lesson that mean farting camels
gold can meet a gold here oh fuck off
fuck God Oh double fuck off
oh fuck you there's no more walking fuck
you
totally made me forget walk it was in
this movie that's its greatest crime
were real we up with the white beep in
there because you know he's really there
guys this is fucking master of disguise
where they need like the filler oh my
god shit someone call my agent write any
tunes related Jewish shit fuck you don't
deserve to eat the corn out of Porky's
numbers shit and I don't want watch the
Christmas walk oh I go put this out
there this probably wouldn't be nearly
as bad if we didn't watch Green Lantern
before it I feel like this is half bad
movie half just giving out the saved up
sober resentment before a Green Lantern
I spent like two thirds of this movie
with my face down planted on the floor
that still you weren't even half of it
you coward you spent half of it on the
full heart I did face down and just
listening to it and then I would look up
and then my eyes would burn got here
which ones worse cream lantern or
kangaroo jack
I'm still gonna say Green Lantern I miss
agreement I'm gonna say Green Lantern
this is how to shoot orange so bye are
you gonna be able to turn the camera off
probably not
fuck sake
you